i am joined this hour by noted hate
monger
vicious bigot
uh a misogynistic trans-phobic
friend of mine his name is matt walsh he
is the erstwhile number one best-selling
lgbt author in the united states author
of johnny the walrus a really tremendous
children's book and most recently the
star
of an episode
of dr phil matt thanks for coming on
thank you thank you for that
introduction i really appreciate it
anytime accurate
so
matt you just
for the handful of people who had not
heard of you in the country they just
heard of you because you went viral
after being invited onto the dr phil
daytime talk show where you were brought
on to defend the view that men can't
become women and you were debating this
position
with
a a very
sexually ambiguous person who looked
somewhat like a woman but also had a
beard and it was extraordinarily
confusing
yeah yeah it was uh it was i was on
there with two there were diversity
consultants and one was uh i believe
one's trans one identifies as non-binary
one's a was a man who who kind of
presents as a woman the other was a you
know female who presents as a man uh and
i think they were also romantic couples
as well but nothing nothing that matters
and i'm also there was also a professor
um kind of a woke professor there as
well and i think she's a communications
professor and for some reason she was
brought on to talk about gender
and as along with the entire studio
audience and the interesting thing of
course so i'm kind of outnumbered on the
stage for most of the for most of the
discussion yeah then they brought a
couple other sane people up towards the
end
um and people have asked people are you
you know nervous going into that
environment knowing you're gonna be
outnumbered you're in front of a hostile
audience and the thing is if this was
any kind of complicated subject that
required me to be intelligent
and uh well-spoken i i would have
absolutely been nervous i probably would
have said no but if my position is
simply that um individuals with penises
are men like that's that's my and if you
can give birth you're a woman then yeah
there's nothing to be afraid of you
could walk in front of any audience
doesn't matter at all because your
position is very very simple and of
course what we know and if you watch the
episode what you see as i'm trying to do
is um
because you have the you have simplicity
on your side because the truth is simple
here and so they're going to try to
constantly
they can't engage with you so they're
going to try to pull you into the weeds
and make everything seem really obscure
and uh and and complicated you just
don't understand right exactly and so
all you have to do and unfortunately i
see people on the right get sucked into
that all the time
but just you you just stay on the firm
ground of what is the simple truth of
the matter and don't leave from there
let let them equivocate and um hang
around in the weeds you just stay stay
on your firm ground of truth and i think
it all works out one real takeaway i had
from your appearance on dr phil
which you know i haven't watched a ton
of daytime tv in recent years so i
really think you brought that to a whole
new audience
besides just understanding that you were
right and these looney tunes on the
other side were extremely mistaken it
actually
made me question
the value of dialogue with with the
people who share basically no premises
with you they're completely on the other
side we're always told that it's so
important that we speak to people who
have totally opposing views to us but
is that important is there anything
fruitful that is going to come out of
talking to someone who just simply
doesn't share any first principles
so you're saying when you hear me speak
it makes you question the value of
dialogue at all
that's that's how effective it's a
compliment somehow
um yeah i i
during that episode i i'm not sure how
much of it made it into in ontario but
uh towards the end dr phil himself was
talking about i thought he was very fair
by the way in the way that he uh kind of
navigated this and refereed it but
towards the end he was he was trying to
find some sort of positive takeaway from
all this and so he was talking about how
hey like there's a value of conversation
we've had a conversation here and uh so
this only shows that we could keep
talking about this issue and all of that
but you know i'm thinking the exact same
thing as you is if anything this is
proven that you can't talk to these
people but
there there's still value in the
conversation because i the way that i
look at it uh when i'm talking about
this issue or talking to someone in
front of an audience this is really for
the audience because there are a lot of
people yeah someone someone who's
totally fallen into gender ideology
you're not going to be able to retrieve
them from it through one conversation
and so as far as that conversation goes
they're kind of hopeless unfortunately
but there are a lot of just normal sane
people out there
who understand
how crazy this is but but they've
they've been conditioned they live in an
environment where this is shoved down
their throat every second of the day
maybe after a while they start to
question their own sanity and they start
to think well i don't know i mean i i
think that only women can give birth but
everyone is shouting at me that it's
different so maybe they're right and
then for them i think there are a lot of
people that are sort of on the cusp of
of of buying into this
and they can be rescued all they need to
hear is some normal person saying no no
you're you're right about what you
thought to begin with and what everybody
thought up until 15 seconds ago you're
right about that it's okay to have that
viewpoint and let me show you how right
you are i think i think that's where the
um where the value comes in so the point
of the dialogue is not the
looney tune that you're talking to very
often but it's it's the spectators
it's how there are two different kinds
of debate there's debate when you go sit
with someone over a cigar late at night
private environment and you try to
persuade one another of what you think
and if you share at least certain basic
premises maybe you'll succeed in that
and then there's public debate which is
you're just trying to clobber the other
guy you're trying to say that guy's
wrong my view is right and it's up to
the audience to decide i think that's a
good point obviously
we need to persuade people and so we
need to present our views they need to
get a hearing in public
but it is amazing because
though we live in this world now where
everything has to be empirical and based
on some study and we have to have the
evidence for every single thing
a lot of our public debates
boil down to
first principles if i think that
human beings are just
walking meat puppets just bags of
chemicals where everything that we hope
for and love and and feel joy over it's
really just an illusion caused by
synapses just squirting out chemicals
and when we die we turn to worm food and
take a dirt nap that i'm going to have a
very different understanding of the
world than someone who thinks that man
is made in the image and likeness of god
and
how do you convince how do you convince
someone to go over to the other side
yeah it's true although the interesting
thing is that even if you you you start
from that first premise of that we're
all meat puppets and biological machines
and so on i mean even from that premise
you still can't really get to
transgenderism so uh that's that's what
makes it so interesting that's one of
the reasons why
um i was maybe a little bit surprised
and look at the reaction of the dr phil
episode it was it's been overwhelmingly
positive i mean overwhelming you can
even go to um
dr phil's youtube page and you can look
at the clips that he posted and just
read some of the comments and that's not
always a scientific way of determining
public opinion but it can be revealing
and it's just overwhelmingly um on the
side of sanity here what that tells me
is that like most people understand how
crazy this is and in a way people are
sort of i guess you have to give people
permission to be sane you know in this
environment and that's that's one thing
that we can do um that's important but
then it's also frustrating because i
know there's some conservatives that
take solace in this idea of the silent
majority but um it's also frustrating in
a way because well if we're the majority
why are we silent and if if 90 of people
or 99 know how crazy this is which i
think they do
then why why have we allowed any of this
to happen i mean why is it that you can
go anywhere in the country and there are
men competing against women in women's
sports and men in the women's room
restroom and all that kind of stuff
um it shows the the power that we have
and it also shows that this other side
um
breaks down
in an instant all you have to do is just
turn and face it and ask one simple
question and it breaks down
um and yet to this point we really
haven't done that and that's the
frustrating part you know people need
people need some limits
this when i watch you talking to
gender ambiguous people and you don't
know if it's a man or a woman and it
seems to me that self-expression has
gone a little bit
too far and and
i saw this the other day i'd love for
you to weigh in since you are a
self-described theocratic fascist
there's a town up in alaska canai alaska
and at their assembly meeting in this
town
they have an individual will come up and
and present an invocation this is just
part of the way the assembly operates
and anyone can go do it so you know you
get a presbyterian goes up there gives
an invocation or a catholic or a
methodist or
so
recently they had a satanist go up and
give a satanic invocation
i am told
by the liberals and by some
people on the right even
that this is
this is the meaning of religious liberty
if we matt if you and i want religious
liberty in this country then we need to
allow some of our representatives to
publicly worship satan in government
buildings is that
have they missed something
yeah i think they have that's reminds me
of that i think what was the school
system somewhere last week or two weeks
ago that had an after-school satan club
and so it's kind of along those lines
and that's why i know you you have been
as well uh i'm critical of what you hear
even on the right about um
well we just what we really want is uh
open dialogue and we want we want
alternative viewpoints to be to be
allowed and yeah um you know this is all
about openness and everything and even
when when these people on the right are
complaining about
conservative views being
banned from campuses they always frame
their complaint as one of wanting just
openness and free expression academic
freedom right right and but that's
that's not really the problem the
problem is is that it's not that it's
not that uh freedom is being banned from
camp it's that truth so this is we're
seeing we're seeing truth being edged
out of education education has to be
grounded in truth or otherwise it's not
education at all and so i think that's
the way we need to start talking about
it you know what is true this guy he's
saying that men are not women he's
saying satan should not be uh hailed and
worshipped in our government you you
really you're everything they say about
you matt a theocratic fascist a monster
but thank you at least for clarifying
the positions and this is a fruitful
dialogue others maybe not so much matt
walsh go check out the matt walsh show